[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen im Sport
können Sie sich auf Fußball freuen von
Norbert LEH schön guten Abend auch von
mir schauen wir auf unsere großen
Nachrichten
Themen klare Signale in der Krisenregion
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
bekräftigt die bundeswehrpräsenz im
Libanon unds sichert Israels Armee
Unterstützung
zu auf dem Weg zur Parteigründung Sarah
Wagenknecht und ihre Unterstützer wollen
offenbar als neue politische Kraft
durchstarten für die Linkspartei wird
das zur
Zerreißprobe und hoffen auf Berlin und
Brüssel im saalland plant die
Stahlindustrie den Umbau auf grüne
Energie drängt aber noch auf Milliarden
Fördergelder die weltweiten
diplomatischen versuche den Krieg im
Nahen Osten zu deeskalieren laufen auf
Hochturen bundesaußenministerin berbor
ist jetzt erneut in die Region gereist
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius war
heute in Israel genauso wie der
britische Premierminister sunneek über
die aktuelle Lage in Israel und Gaza
berichten l walpot und Ines
trums auch in der vergangenen Nacht
Griff Israel wieder zahlreiche Ziele im
Gazastreifen an laut Armee sollen dabei
mehrere hochrangige hamasmitglieder
getötet Kommandozentralen und Tunnel
zerstört worden sein die
palästinensische Seite sprach
zahlreichen Toten und
Verletzten die Familien meines Onkels
und meiner Tante sind tot um 7 Uhr
morgens hörten wir die Explosion die
ganze Straße war
zerstört unterdessen traf
Außenministerin bärbock in Aman ein in
Gesprächen mit ihrem jordanischen
Amtskollegen kündigte sie weitere Hilfen
für die palästinensische
Zivilbevölkerung an berburg wird morgen
nach Israel weiterreisen dort traf
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
heute mit seinem Amtskollegen galant
zusammen Deutschland unterstütze Israel
im Kampf gegen den Terrorismus so
Pistorius es sei aber auch wichtig Opfer
zu vermeiden wo immer es möglich ist so
wie es das Völkerrecht für uns alle
vorgibt und doch das ist eine große
Herausforder am Morgen hatte Pistorius
deutsche Marinesoldaten in berirut
besucht die im Rahmen der
Blauhelmmission UNIFIL dort stationiert
sind der Minister unterstricht die
Bedeutung des Einsatzes für die
Sicherheit in der Region weil ich schon
glaube dass jetzt angesichts der
Entwicklung nach dem Terrorangriff der
Hamas auf Israel sich die Situation
natürlich
weiter weiter dramatisch entwickeln kann
an der Grenze vom Libanon nach Israel
gab es erneut heftigen
Artilleriebeschuss das auswerärtige Amt
hat deutsche staatsangehörigge
aufgerufen den Libanon zu verlassen aus
Ägypten sollen unterdessen morgen erste
Hilfslieferungen für die notleidende
Bevölkerung in den Gazastreifen gebracht
werden und aus Israel gibt es jetzt die
Nachricht dass Verteidigungsminister
galant den Truppen gesagt hat dass sie
den palästinensischen Küstenstreifen
bald Zitat von innen sehen würden
Michael bewerunge in Israel wie ist das
einzuschätzen das ist eine Nachricht die
die Menschen die hier vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium seit Tagen für
die Freilassung ihrer Angehörigen den
Geiseln im in Gaza demonstrieren hart
treffen wird denn damit steht fest die
lang angekündigte Bodenoffensive über
die spekuliert worden ist wann und ob
sie überhaupt noch stattfinden wird sie
wird kommen auch der Kommandeur der
Truppen im Süden hat gesagt wir werden
den Krieg auf ihr Territorium tragen
gemeindestier Hamas und Gaza und heute
Abend noch soll das Kabinett
zusammentreten um diesen nächsten
Schritt offiziell zu beschließen wann
genau diese Bodenoffensive starten wird
ist noch nicht eindeutig aber eines ist
klar dieser Krieg tritt in eine neue
Phase der Eskalation danke für diese
Einordnung Michael
bberunger um den Krieg im Nahen Osten
und um damit zusammenhängende
antisemitische Vorfälle in Deutschland
ging es heute auch in einer
Regierungserklärung von Kanzler Scholz
in den Bundestag kam auch aus Israel
Angehörige von Geiseln die von der
Hammers festgehalten werden Dorte Ferber
berichtet sie sind nach Deutschland
gekommen in den Bundestag um Gehör zu
finden
Angehörige der Geiseln Treffen am Morgen
die
Parlamentspräsidentin Ronis Schwester
wurde verschleppt im Schlafanzug die
Familie bislang ohne Nachricht ri
appelliert wir werden weiter von den
Terroristen angegriffen das endet noch
nicht und Deutschland muss schnell
handeln wir brauchen das die Zeit läuft
ab der regiererlung icher Bundeskanzler
erneut Deutschlands Platz sei an der
Seite Israels auch hier zuande dürfe
nicht weggeschaut werden bei
Versammlungen bei denen der Tod von
Menschen verherrlicht werde
Antisemitismus ist in Deutschland fehl
am Platze und wir werden alles dafür tun
ihn gegen ihn uns zu stellen wir werden
das machen als Bürger und Bürger als
diejenigen die politisch Verantwortung
haben es ist hier auch eine klare Kante
gefragt wir zeigen sie gemeinsam in
Deutschland im Parlament überparteilich
gegen gewaltsame und antisemitische
Proteste müsse entschieden vorgegangen
werden wenn der Satz richtig ist und er
ist richtig dass Judenhass und
Zerstörungswut gegen Israel keinen Platz
in unserem Land haben dürfen dann ist
jetzt ein hartes Durchgreifen der
Polizei und der Justiz angezeigt meine
den her jüdisches Leben gehört zu
Deutschland wer das nicht erträgt der
gehört nicht zu Deutschland meine Damen
und Herren
einig und entschlossen der Bundestag
heute nach den antisemitischen
Ausschreitungen der Koordinationsrat der
Muslime in Deutschland zu dem unter
anderem der Zentralrat der Muslime
gehört hat sich in einer Erklärung vom
Zitat terroristischen Anschlag gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung in Israel durch die
Hamas distanziert zudem erklärte der Rat
die inakzeptablen Taten einer marginalen
Kleingruppe in Berlin werden so
dargestellt als ob sie für alle Muslime
in Deutschland repräsentativ sein gerade
in Berlin ist es zuletzt mehrmals im
Stadtteil Neuköln zu Ausschreitungen bei
proalästinensischen Protesten gekommen
teils wurden Feuerwerkskörper und
Flaschen geworfen Polizeikräfte wurden
verletzt und es gab vorläufige
Festnahmen wie denken die Menschen hier
über den Konflikt Roman leskova und
Stefanie Hein berichten Neuköln am Tag
danach vieler Orts wird über die
geschehennisse rund um die Sonnenallee
diskutiert Hamas Sympathisant dem
Verbote Krawalle mit uns sprechen will
hier fast niemand die wenigen die Reden
bewegen ganz unterschiedliche Dinge ich
möchte dass alles so friedlich läuft mit
Frieden also friedlichke hat kann man
auch viel erreichen für Israel wird
alles gemacht aber für Gaza gar nichts
man darf sich gar nicht malr äußern da
muss man für alle Rechte suchen und
nicht dann immer sagen okay jetzt Israel
oder Gaza ist egal das ist Mensch abends
möchte ich hier in dieser Umgebung auch
nicht mehr sein das regt mich auf und ja
das finde ich auch bedrohlich die ganze
Situation gestern Nacht waren die
Ausschreitungen deutlich heftiger als
den Tag zuvor hunderte waren erneut
zusammengekommen ohne offizielle
Anmeldung 174 Festnahmen 65 verletzte
Einsatzkräfte zählt die Polizei Stein
und Flaschenwürfe brennende Barrikaden
die Stimmung erneut aggressiv es wird
gesagt wir stehen hinter Israel aber wer
ist wir jeder Mensch hat hier seine
eigene Meinung und teilweise die meisten
Leute hier die hier sind sind auf der
Seite von Palästina ich bin hier um
meine Stimme weiterzuleiten dass die
Palästinenser dort auch Menschen würde
haben im neukölner Rathaus geht man von
rund 20.000 palästinensis stämmigen
Bewohnern im Bezirk aus Steine Werfer
seinen kaum erreichbar andere schon
nicht jeder der Verwandte und Bekannte
in den im Westjordanland oder im
Gazastreifen hat ist automatisch auch
jemand der den Staat Israel von ein
Landkarte radieren möchte so und
diejenigen müssen wir eben laut machen
die müssen wir unterstützen gerade in
dieser jetzigen Situation zwei Nächte in
Folge gab es jetzt Ausschreitungen in
Neuköln die Polizei ist auch heute
wachsam
über den Krieg in Israel und Gaza
kursieren gerade in den sozialen Medien
viele Falschinformation und Hassreden
die EU-Kommission erhöht jetzt den Druck
auf den Facebook Konzern Meta sowie auf
tiktok innerhalb einer bestimmten Frist
müssen sie erklären welche Maßnahmen sie
ergriffen haben um z.B terroristische
oder waltätige Inhalte auf ihren
Plattformen zu verhindern und
Falschinformationen
einzudämmen blicken wir in die Ukraine
dort ist Tag 603 des Krieges im Süden
beierson hat die Armee erneut ein
Vorstoß unternommen auf die Russisch
besetzte Seite des Flusses den nipro
doch offenbar wurde sie wieder
zurückgeschlagen die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive stockt und sie ist
kräftezehrend fordert Tag für Tag auch
viele Verletzte dring benötigt Blut die
Spendebereitschaft in der Ukraine ist
groß eine brö
berichtet die Schlange ist lang an
diesem Morgen im Blutspendezentrum von
Kiev die meisten sind hier weil sie
wissen dass ihr Blut gebraucht wird auch
für die Soldaten an der
Front jetzt verlieren wir so viele
Menschen viele verlieren so viel Blut
man muss diese Verluste
ausgleichen ich will der Gesellschaft
meinem Volk helfen wenn ich Blutspenden
kann ist das das wenigste was ich machen
kann Blutspenden für die die ihr Land
verteidigen gegen den russischen
Angriffskrieg für die die bei Raketen
und Drohnenangriffen verletzt werden
seit Beginn des Kriegs hat die Zahl der
Blutspenden in der Ukraine um 60%
zugenommen angefangen hat es am 24
Februar wir sehen seitdem dass wir jetzt
mehr Blutspender
haben sie wissen dass ihr Blut für einen
guten Zweck verwendet wird wir haben
jetzt einen großen
Bedarf das ist ein Symbol der Liebe und
der
Fürsorge vor dem Krieg hat das Zentrum
vor allem die Krankenhäuser beliefert
für Operationen nach Unfällen jetzt geht
vieles von hier gleich an die
Front wir können alle Bedürfnisse die es
gibt
abdecken sowohl für die zivile
Bevölkerung als auch für unsere
Streitkräfte Hilfe für Soldaten für die
Opfer in einem Krieg dessen Ende nicht
absehbar
ist und die militärische Lage in der
Ukraine ist heute auch Thema bei heute
live um 19:30 Uhr in der ZF heute App
und auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen nach Deutschland Sarah
Wagenknecht und die Partei DIE LINKE
dass diese Verbindung bald der
Geschichte anhören könnte hat sich
angedeutet am Montag stellt die
54-Jährige einen Verein vor als mögliche
Grundlage für eine eigene Partei und wer
der dann wohl Beitritt das wird nun
konkreter zugleich mehren sich Stimmen
ihrer noch Genossinen und genossen mit
dem Vorwurf auch die linkenfaktion
könnte bald der Geschichte angehören
Daniel
ponzen heute Vormittag gab es noch
Applaus für Amira Mohamed Ali aus der
Fraktion deren Vorsitzende sie offiziell
noch ist am Mittag wurde dann bekannt
dass sie am Montag mit dabei sein soll
wenn SAR Wagenknecht ihren Verein
vorstellt ich finde das sehr falsch aber
eine Überraschung ist es für mich nicht
das wäre auch schlecht wenn ich das
jetzt erfahren hätte ich habe alles
versucht dass die Linke als Fraktion
zusammen bleibt dass wir unsere Aufgabe
die uns Wählerinnen und Wähler gegeben
haben wahrnehmen das ist offensichtlich
in dieser Form nicht möglich jetzt wird
es eine neue eine andere
konkurrenzpartei geben verlassen zwei
oder mehr Abgeordnete die Fraktion der
Linken verliert diese den
Fraktionsstatus und damit
parlamentarische Rechte viele
fraktionsmitarbeiter verlieren möglich
ihren Job nein das wird die Linke nicht
zerreißen wir fordern aber
selbstverständlich alle auf die jetzt
eine neue Partei gründen ihre Mandate
niederzulegen die ja für die Linke
gewonnen wurden und auf Grundlage des
Parteiprogramms der Linken weil es wäre
natürlich ein Gebot des Anstands eine
Antwort darauf dürfte es Montag geben
zud dem mehr dazu wo Wagenknecht und Co
inhaltlich stehen und zur Abgrenzung zur
AFD darüber gab indirekt womöglich
bereits jüngst eine Äußerung Mohammed
Alis Aufschluss nachdem die CDU in
Thüringen mit Stimmen der AFD einen
Antrag durchgebracht hatte gab es von
der Linken Spitze dafür scharfe Kritik
von ihr nicht was die Union hier gemacht
hat ist einfach ganz normales
parlamentarisches Vorgehen sie
hatosition Antrag eingebracht und der
ist abgestimmt worden ja und wenn dann
ein Ergebnis rauskommt was man nicht gut
findet dann muss man damit halt umgehen
so ist Demokratie laut parteienforschern
könnte die AFD noch mehr Prozentpunkte
als die Linke an eine wagenknechtpartei
verlieren deren Gründung erwarten
Insider für Januar sodass sie im juni
bei der Europawahl antreten
könnte bis nach Berlin und auch nach
Brüssel sollte heute der Protest
Tausender saarländischer Stahlarbeiter
innen dringen denn sie fürchten um die
Zukunft ihrer Industrie Start mit Kohle
und Koks sollen sie ab
2024 mit grüner Energie wie Wasserstoff
Stahl herstellen dazu sind Wirtschaft
und Politik im Saarland bereit 3,5
Milliarden Euro braucht es für diesen
Umbau aber die bislang versprochenen
Fördergelder sind noch nicht da die Zeit
drängt und der Druck bei den
Beschäftigten der Stahlindustrie wächst
wie Susanne Freitag cateron
berichtet ihre Schicht findet heute auf
der Straße statt Sternmarsch der
Stahlarbeiter über 10 000 sind unterwegs
sie kämpfen für die Zukunft ihrer
Jobs die Zukunft habe ich hier dabei ne
extra mitgehommen
und alles von vorer Zeit von Vater von
Urgroßvater meine Zeit jetzt so steht
sehr viel
Spiel schon am Morgen hatten über 5000
Stahlarbeiter in Dillingen demonstriert
gemeinsam mit ihrer Unternehmensleitung
und mit der saarändischen
Ministerpräsidentin der Stahl soll grün
werden das kostet Milliarden sie
brauchen Fördergeld aus Brüssel und
Berlin und das ist noch nicht da es geht
darum dass wir hier die komplettenl
umstellen das kostet sehr viel Geld wir
setzen damit auch politische Vorgaben um
und dafür brauchen wir Fördermittel wir
sind bereit dafür diesen Standort
klimafreundlich umzubauen alles ist
vorbereitet wir brauchen nur noch eine
Unterschrift letztes Wochenende war
Azubi Tag bei saarstal über 500
auszubildende sollen die Fachkräfte von
morgen sein wie Laura Kiefer und Nadin
Wagner aber bleibt der Stahl auch ihre
Zukunft ich hoffe natürlich dass ich
hier bleiben kann
aber man weiß nie genau was die Zukunft
mit sich bringt aber wir machen ja auch
die ganzen Aktion mit der EG Metall in
der Hoffnung dass wir was bewirken
können auch Mitarbeiter von Ford und vom
Einzelhandel demonstrieren heute Abend
mit denn es geht nicht nur um Stahl
sondern um die Zukunft einer ganzen
Region der diesjährige sacharovpreis für
geistige Freiheit geht postum an die
Iranerin Gina Mar
zugleich wird die Frauenbewegung in Iran
ausgezeichnet die 22jährige amen war im
September vergangenen Jahres von
sogenannten Sittenwächtern festgenommen
und geschlagen worden Vorwurf sie habe
ihr Kopftuch falsch getragen im Polizei
Gewahrsam starb Gina maa Amini ihr Tod
löste eine beispiellose Protestwelle für
die Rechte von Frauen und gegen das
Regime
aus an der Ostsee bereiten sich die
Menschen auf eine stmflut vor einige
fairlinien haben bereits teilweise oder
ganz den Betrieb eingestellt in
Travemünde überschwemmten erste
Ausläufer die Promenade was weggespült
werden könnte wurde in Sicherheit
gebracht auch in Dänemark sind erste
vorbotende Sturmtiefs angekommen die
Polizei forderte die Menschen dort auf
die Küste bis morgen früh zu
verlassen zur Fußball Champions League
der Frau Norbert Frankfurt top wburg
Flop ja Unerwartetes für die Wölfin
schon in der Qualifikation 0:2 bei Paris
FC ganz stark dagegen die Frankfurterin
nach dem 130 Sieg bei Sparta Prag hat
die Eintracht erstmals die Gruppenphase
erreicht sie bekommt den Abgang der ihr
gebührt Barbara Dunst schießt Frankfurt
in die Champions League der
Österreicherin gelingen alle Treffer zum
3:0 Sieg der Eintracht über Sparta Prag
alle in der ersten Halbzeit ein Hattrick
also Frankfurt in der Königsklasse das
war schon nach dem 5:0 im Hinspiel
Formsache für mir war einfach wichtig
dass wir heute da den Sack zumachen und
in die Gruppenphase gehen und trotzdem
aber gute Performance abliefern dank
ihrer Treffsicherheit ist auch das
Rückspiel sein Eintrittsgeld wert ganz
anders die Gefühlslage bei Alexandra Pop
und dem VfL Wolfsburg nichts läuft
zusammen gegen Paris FC die Französinnen
gehen vor der Pause durch dufur in
Führung es ist vielleicht einfach auch
gerade zu wenig und vielleicht am
stückit gar nicht unverdient ein
verschossen
von weiteres Tor der Französinnen zum
Schluss lassen Wolfsburg zum ersten Mal
seit 2012 zuschauen in der Champions
League im Topspiel der zweiten
Fußballbundesliga der Männer empfängt
Düsseldorf am Samstag Kaisers Lautern
und das Besondere die Zuschauer müssen
keinen Eintritt zahlen Auftag des
vielbeachteten Düsseldorfer Projekts
Fortuna für
alle erstmals in der laufenden Saison
wird dieses Stadion am Samstag voll sein
Fortuna Düsseldorf startet eine Ticket
rution im Profifußball der Verein hat
für die anstehende Zweitliga Partie alle
54 000 Tickets kostenlos verteilt
Sponsoren gleichen die fehlenden
ticketterlöse aus so ein Weg ja sind die
Mannschaften bei denen ich bisher tätig
war nicht gegangen und von daher bin ich
natürlich persönlich bin ich unheimlich
gespannt was uns da erwartet mit der
Aktion Fortuna für alle sollen die Fans
stärker an den Verein gebunden werden
für zwei weitere Heimspiele werden
2024 ebenfalls alle Tickets umsonst
vergeben ja bin ja mal gespannt ob
andere Vereine dem Beispiel folgen
werden danke schön Arbeit Sturm und
Hochwasser wir haben eben schon ein
bisschen darüber berichtet dazu viel
Regen ist beim Wetter angesagt mehr dazu
gleich von östen terli um etwa :4 Uhr
können Sie das heute journal sehen mit
Marietta Slomka
[Musik]
wiedersehen
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir haben es mit
einem ungewöhnlichen fast
gesamteuropäischen Sturmtief zu tun was
sehr viel Wind aus dem Osten bringen
wird also eine ungewöhnliche Zugbahn und
Windrichtung und sie sehen hier auch
viel Regen der durchziehen wird und der
Wind ist vor allem im Norden sehr heftig
teils orkanartige böhnen an den Küsten
hier richt ichtung flenzburger Förde
lübeckerbucht und kielerbucht teilweise
2 m über normal wird das Wasser
ansteigen ganz im Süden gibt's auch viel
Wind hier Föhnsturm aber Föhnsturm ist
hier fast untertrieben bis zu 140 km pro
Stunde sind möglich in der kommenden
Nacht viel Regen der nach Norden zieht
viel Wind an den Küsten der sich aufbaut
und ganz im Süden erstmal trocken das
bei Temperaturen von 4° im Osten und 13°
im Westen morgen dann weiterer Regen der
nach Norden sich lagert wie schon
berichtet der Sturm hier im Norden und
die Sturmflut und an den Alpen viel
windteils orkanböhnen bei 6 bis 22° mit
fönunterstützung und die nächsten Tage
am Samstag noch ruppig und ab Sonntag
wird's ruhiger ein schönen Abend